heute geht es heiß her bei klicks um ihr
seht warum cacau nicht brennt oder doch
und was man alles mit wunderkerzen an
ständern zuvor eine bitte nicht
nachmachen
wer hierbei nicht extrem vorsichtig ist
kann sich ernsthaft verletzen
chemie ist nicht selten ziemlich
verblüffend und das beste wenn man ein
bisschen mit physik nach hilft dann
reagieren stoffe oftmals viel extremer
sei es dass einfach mehr stoff da ist
oder dass der stoff anders verteilt ist
oder unter druck steht aber bitte
vorsicht vorsicht vorsicht die heutigen
experimente habe ich mit sachen gemacht
die es in jedem haushalt gibt
kakaopulver und wunderkerzen
fangen wir mal mit dem kakaopulver an es
will einfach nicht brennen
dabei reagiert sauerstoff so gerne mit
allerlei substanzen
doch entscheidend für die reaktion ist
zum beispiel die entzündungs temperatur
oder auch die oberfläche also die fläche
auf der der sauerstoff mit der substanz
reagieren umso größer sie ist umso
leichter kann der sauerstoff reagieren
und es brennt oder es passiert wenn es
mehr will der kakao also nicht brennen
muss einfach nur eine möglichst große
oberfläche erzeugt werden und was liegt
da näher als mit kakao feuer zu spucken
und das ist ganz simpel einfach den
kakao in den mund löffeln und kräftig
pusten
durch die feine verteilung des
kakaopulver es wird eine riesige
oberfläche erzeugt und bei kontakt mit
einer flamme brennt das pulver
explosionsartig ab also mit ganz
harmlosen stoffen kann man schon
ziemlich gefährliche sachen machen
deshalb sind staub explosionen so
befürchtet auf wunderkerzen haben es im
wahrsten sinne des wortes in sich wie
normales feuer können sie unter wasser
gelöscht werden doch vorsicht
wunderkerzen brauchen eigentlich keinen
sauerstoff um zu brennen
sie tragen nämlich ihr eigenes
oxidationsmittel in sicht das heißt
oxidieren eis ja ein stoff reagiert mit
sauerstoff und sie haben den sauerstoff
zum brennen schon in sich denn gelöscht
werden sie durch das wasser nur durch
die abkühlung nicht durch den
sauerstoffmangel bündelt man also
genügend wunderkerzen müssten sie auch
unter wasser bringen
für dieses experiment sind allerdings
ein paar vorsichtsmaßnahmen zu treffen
und wie man hier in köln sagt was für
ein wird herrlich anzusehen ja also
wunderkerzen brennen unter wasser
und auch mit etwas druck können
wunderkerzen zu einem beeindruckenden
schauspiel bewegt werden wir zu werden
wieder einige wunderkerzen gebündelt und
mit klebeband fest zusammen gekippt
hierdurch läuft die verbrennung
spektakulärer exklusiver ab das wird ein
wahrer augenschmaus
denn bevor die wunderkerzen abbrennen
wird erstmal die temperatur ordentlich
erhöht aber eine verbrennung kann noch
nicht stattfinden weil es keine
möglichkeit gibt sich auszudehnen erst
wenn der druck so stark ist dass die
schüler auch gesprengt werden kann
dann beginnt die verbrennen da nun aber
die entzündungs temperatur nahezu
überall erreicht ist findet die
verbrennung schlagartig statt
das war der spaß rund um cacau und
wunderkerzen gema nachzulesen auf dem
blog und wenn er noch mehr sehen wollt
dann gibt es da warum flugzeuge fliegen
oder auch nicht bis dann bleibt dran